well thank you for joining us at 11 on
this friday night i'm brian loftis
former president donald trump back here
in las vegas today stumping for
republican candidates adam laxalt and
joe lombardo now it was a private event
over at treasure island but outside
protesters made their voices heard up
and down the strip sasha loftis was
there joining us now live in our 8 news
now newsroom with a bit more
brian former president trump was here to
push for both adam laxalt and joe
lombardo who both recently won their
primary races here in nevada the private
event featured what organizers called
hand-picked supporters
[Applause]
former president donald trump making a
stop in las vegas friday
to stump for republican candidates for
nevada governor and u.s senate joe
lombardo and adam laxalt it's great to
be in a crowd of friends the private
event held at treasure island featured a
panel and discussion about their plans
for the future if they're elected you
need to elect america first republicans
at every level various topics including
a crackdown on crime and enforcement at
the border were discussed we need to get
serious about this border we need to do
it immediately i need you to stand
together arms interlocked and say we
will not take it anymore along with a
push for awareness and harsher
punishment for drug-related crimes one
is we got to make people aware of it the
volatility associated with it the former
president's attendance did bring
controversy with some protesting along
the strip nevadans have already rejected
donald trump twice and they will reject
him and his policies again
in november but the energy inside was
evident as those here pushed for change
at the polls in november i am the right
person to change that paradigm
now president trump did start today's
speech on a somber note offering his
condolences to the former japanese prime
minister shinzo abe who was shot and
killed during a campaign speech this
week reporting live in the newsroom
tonight sasha loftis live local now